we were romantic for like a night former
bachelorette Ali Fedotowsky man Oh drops
a bombshell that left OG bachelorette
fans really told anybody this but after
Roberto and I broke up I actually went
on a date with Frank and we were
romantic for like a knight bachelor
nation will never forget the
gut-wrenching exit of contestant Frank
who left Ali heartbroken during season
six of the hit ABC show there was
something that was you know holding me
back and makes me unresolved feelings
for an ex-girlfriend
and on mondays big Bachelorette reunion
Ali revealed the pair reunited after her
engagement to the show's winner Roberto
Martinez and did et sat down with the
show's host Chris Harrison ahead of the
reunion and what was that like for you
to be with all of those women again and
take that moment in I just watched the
whole thing last night and I was I was
like a five-year-old at Christmas I
really was I was I was had this weird
sense of pride I guess it's not weird
it's my baby and so and I and I really
love these women and I really liked it
at the end of the day we had all these
bachelorettes together for the first
time we've never done anything like it
so maybe there was this novelty thing to
it where I'm just watching them just be
them and they were having this cocktail
thing where they were just sitting
around talking and telling stories of
motherhood and just being women today
and being bachelorettes and going
through this show and I just thought
this is great
it's just celebrating these badass women
doing their thing and there was no
producing no nothing it was just raw
them and and then it would then having
them laid out lined up in the driveway
later that night and I like looking from
Trista to Becca and I'm like wow we did
this like this all these kick-ass women
doing their thing
and I know I thought was pretty cool